thanks for being here fellas oh it's my
pleasure i'm
thrilled yeah you know i got to say uh
every time i see something you make me
laugh you're so talented ah
you really are that means a lot you went
huh
no i don't much about i was reading
about you today you're from cleveland
yeah
and uh really now they just want to
get themselves on tv later make a noise
and later we'll watch it in a bar
um is your was your family in show
business at all what kind of
no i'm the only one my dad my dad was uh
owned a business called ohio computer
ribbon and supply
uh which um was he had a
basically like rent he what he is known
for in my family
is being the most frugal human being in
america like he is
he's the cheapest person you could
possibly
imagine and i'm saying this with all due
respect right
he wants he went to notre dame this is
an example i have two younger brothers
and he would
take my he would make my brother who was
maybe 10 at the time
uh drive with him to south bend put
a fake sling on and suck his son so that
he could get in for free to the game
you know if there was a birthday like my
mom for a birthday like he'd go to
baskin robbins and he would wait to see
who didn't pick up their cakes and bring
home
cakes that said like happy birthday
charles and give them too much
for your mom thought it was hilarious
and we all did too actually to me
yeah and he saved a lot of money doing
that he was he's so proud of it
was it embarrassing to you as a kid
because when you're i mean now you can
laugh at things like that but when
you're a kid
if your dad's doing something that
embarrasses you it feels
so much like we would go like so much
more powerful
we would go we would take road trips of
course all of our vacations were road
trips and
we would go to like ski resorts in the
summer
and there would be like pictures of us
on like a ski lift in august in
pennsylvania
um and then one time we went to
washington d.c
and we we wanted to see the lincoln
memorial and there was it was packed
and the only available spot was a
handicapped parking spot
and my mom was like bill han don't do it
don't do it and he just took his huge
hilarious very old caddy pulled right
into it he's like we're just gonna we're
just gonna take a quick picture kids get
back in the car
and it was of course cop car cop car and
my dad without a beat just turns around
and starts limping back to the car
we were like there you go i took it
that's what's happening i'm happy he got
a ticket
i think that didn't change his ways
though did it no he was right he like
fashioned himself kind of
to the chevy chase of our family's
vacation series
right if we were that's what this is my
character yes i'm the cheapskate that's
what happens what i do that's what i do